hello I'm Harley Stenzel in this video I
will show you a working example of a
composed application with IBM data power
gateway for docker and continuous
integration
I'll make changes to the data power
configuration test them locally then
check them in once the changes are
checked in
I'll show you Jenkins building and
testing the changes I made
I'll start by bringing up my composed
application for development well that
comes up let's bring up a browser we'll
use it for both making changes in the
data power web GUI and for seeing our CI
results in Jenkins now log into data
power in the food domain
I'll drill into the multi-protocol
gateway
for demonstration purposes I'll change
the number of times the HTTP frontside
handler connection can be reused now
that I've made my change I click Save
switching back to the composed
application I can see my change data
power is still working properly I have
one more change to make this one is in
gateway script in my editor I add demo
to the result as soon as I hit save
I see my change reflected in the docker
compose output
now that my changes are complete I'll
review them and check them in
as soon as I push the origin server
triggers my Jenkins CI process in less
than a minute we'll have a result for
this demonstration I use the lab from
interconnect 2017 session 63 81 all the
components demonstrate are part of that
lab and they're also available from
github success
that's one complete iteration through a
data power continuous integration cycle
you could do the next one I've shown you
one simple example of data power with
continuous integration I hope this helps
you see how data power applications can
participate as full citizens in your CI
CD process and DevOps workflow you can
easily integrate data power gateway into
your own tools and processes thank you
for watching